a day earlier the white house had said
president trump would support the covet
relief package passed by congress on
monday
but things changed rapidly within this
residence
and less than 24 hours later this wrench
of a video
was uploaded to trump's twitter feed
effectively ending
congress's victory lap mid-stride the
bill they are now planning to send back
to my desk
is much different than anticipated it
really is
a disgrace for example among the more
than 5 000 pages in this bill
which nobody in congress has read
because of its length and complexity
it's called the coveted relief bill but
it has almost nothing to do
with covert the bill is indeed
massive besides the 900 billion dollars
allocated to covet relief
it includes money for foreign aid the
arts
wildlife management and of course
keeping the federal government
open until september trump is demanding
that congress amend the legislation
to remove the unnecessary items but to
add money to the coven 19 relief portion
the current bill gives six hundred
dollar checks to most americans
trump wants that increase to two
thousand
send me a suitable bill or else the next
administration will have to deliver a
coveted relief package
and maybe that administration will be me
it won't despite trump's continued
refusal to concede the election
joe biden will be sworn in as u.s
president on january 20th
one thing i promise you about my
leadership during this crisis
i'm going to tell it to you straight i'm
going to tell you the truth
speaking earlier in the day biden
commended congress on passage of the
cobit relief bill
while pledging his administration would
indeed ask for more money
our darkest days in the battle against
covet
are ahead of us not behind us
so we need to prepare ourselves to steal
our spines
as frustrating it is to hear it's going
to take
patience more patience than what
americans had been told just a day
earlier by trump's
own treasury secretary who had promised
people would begin receiving those
600 dollar checks approved by congress
next week
now the plan is in limbo congress had
passed the bipartisan measure with veto
proof
super majorities but trump's demands may
give republicans cover to switch their
votes
or it could give democrats ammo to
insist on the bigger checks for
americans that the party had wanted all
along
it had taken months of negotiations to
achieve this
so briefly celebrated progress in
congress
and now the only certainty is trump's
insistence
on leaving a mark during his last days
in office
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington